willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung der
letzten sitzung des interdisziplinären
seminares kann hinter die perspektiven
ich möchte heute nochmal ein rückblick
geben über die wichtigsten der
vergangenen sitzung und dann im
anschluss werden wir noch diskutieren
über einige fragen die ich mir überlegt
habe ja das war dieses titelbild sie
finden es auf perspektiv punkt net
schauen sie vorbei wir werden immer
weiter inhalte reinstellen
zusammenfassung wiki artikeln dieses
projekt ist noch nicht fertig es gewinnt
immer weiter inhalt an kontur
ich möchte jetzt chronologisch anfangen
in unserem sinne des seminars gln
touring was war da das wichtigste das
man sich vielleicht merken sollte ich
mal oben rechts und links zu den
entsprechenden sitzung ein ich
persönlich würde sagen es ist keine als
imitation sie kennen alle das imitation
game und touring zersetzung these wie
ich sie nenne er sagte question kenne
sheens sinkt das ist ja auch die frage
des seminares gewesen sagte schott die
replays bei all der imagine the digital
computer & food duell in die emitec game
also es geht um ein spiel natürlich muss
man sich fragen was ist oder ein spiel
zu verstehen noch ein zitat die regional
question kenner shinkai believe to be
too many ways to deserve discovery lässt
beliebte die entry josef janning will
have it so much the throne will be able
to speak auf maschine thinking and
expected to be connected also hier geht
es auch um vermutungen die er anstellt
ich finde es ganz wichtig dass im rahmen
einer philosophischen diskussion von
künstlichen intelligenz immer auch
gewisse vermutungen gedankenexperimente
es sind nicht nur gedankenexperimente
sind experimente die sich auf die
zukunft einer gewissen entwicklung
beziehen das sind die zulässt dass man
aber dennoch im kritisch gegenüber
stellt steht und so was wie
spekulationen vermeidet die in meinen
augen eben nicht mehr wirklich
philosophisch zu verstehen sind hier ist
also das stichwort karriere als
imitation
dann nächster philosoph den wir
behandelt hatten waren stand
seinem buch my brain science und da wenn
das kapitel kein computer sieg das ist
ja auch die frage die sich elend touring
gestellt hatte der allerdings eben diese
frage um geändert hatte was ja auch eine
philosophische aufgabe ist fragen
richtig zu stellen und fragen
gegebenenfalls auch zu korrigieren und
das problem gut in den blick zu bekommen
ich mache auch hier oben rechts dann den
link wieder ein zu dieser sitzung mit
chance höher hier wäre für mich in
meinen augen der titel k als simulation
treffend und natürlich ganz wichtig ist
wird das verständnis von 12 die
philosophie die unterscheidung zwischen
syntax und semantik also sind excellence
dazwischen von sentix in digital
computer ist in sophies der
computertreff bei definition als zehnter
es gibt also kein übergang von der
syntax den regeln wie wörter verbunden
werden zu der bedeutung dieser worte
er spricht hier allerdings jetzt nur von
einer manipulation von bedeutungslosen
symbolen als er hat den symbolischen
knie dann gebrauch vor augen
diese andere dieser alles andere
paradigma was wir kennen gelernt haben
diese kollektion ist ische ansatz den
erwähnten nicht hier muss man sich jetzt
fragen ob nicht durch den kondition ist
ischen ansatz so was wie bedeutet
vielleicht noch mehr ins zentrum rücken
kann als durch den symbolischen ansatz
das müssen uns fragen und dann sagte
eben auch consciousness ford feelings
emotions and all that involve mortenson
taxis features bei definition der
computer ist unable to public power for
make its ability to stimulate
also hier die ganz zentrale
unterscheidung zwischen publikation das
wäre eine starke auffassung von
künstlicher intelligenz leistung und
große simulation das ist ein streit der
nach wie vor andauert
simuliert künstliche intelligenz nur
intelligenz oder emotionen oder andere
dinge die wir heute auch noch mehr
besprechen werden oder duplizieren als
realisieren sie diese dinge von der
andere weisen das ist eine ganz zentrale
frage
sagt sie simulieren nur
der nächste denke den ich ganz zentral
finde ist hubert dreyfus der jetzt eben
noch diesen anderen ansatz den kondition
ist ein ansatz den modeling ansatz des
gehirns spiel bringt und diskutiert ich
hatte ein paar bücher von ihm damals
gezeigt dass sitzung ich nach oben
rechts den link zu der sitzung ein als
es begann mit chemie und artificial
intelligence aus dem jahr 1964 65 dann
dieser sprechende titel what computers
kannst du limits of artificial
intelligence
1972 und dann
sieben jahre später bordcomputers ilka
du kritik auf atypische riesen ein
weiteres buch hier finde ich ganz
interessant dass er hier nicht vom tisch
fischer intelligence spricht sondern vom
typischen riesen intelligenz und riesen
sind ja nicht genau dasselbe also da
muss man auch mal genau nachdem man
könnte das übersetzt mit eine kritik der
künstlichen vernunft so was ein buch ist
auch nicht geschrieben worden müsste man
mal machen auf deutschland die kritik
der künstlichen vernünftig analogie zur
kritik der reinen vernunft und der
kritik der praktischen vernunft hat ganz
zentral
hier noch eine anekdote
167 verlor über 3 fuß als erster mensch
gegen das schachprogramm mac hektik das
war natürlich kein programm wie wir es
heute kennen
sondern es war ein ziemlich einfaches
programm natürlich hat es eine große
bibliothek mit zügen die ein
programmiert war und so kann man sich
gut aus gut erklären dass auch ein nicht
ungeübter schachspieler dagegen seine
schwierigkeiten gehabt haben könnte
ich möchte hier aus diesem aufsatz von
opel dreyfus making am main wir das ist
model in the brain für meine augen
meinen augen zentrales zitaten vorlesen
freudiger in wittgenstein arbeit human
bios und much more lustig denn wiewohl
netz intelligence story modus ist in die
organismen dort picked up beide sind von
anfang an
alles ist
also hier gibt es die zwei ansätze eben
die neuronalen netze um die symbolisch
programmierte computer und er meint
vermeiden dass sie noch einen weiten weg
zurücklegen müssen diesen beiden ansätze
um wirklich sowas wie einen integrativen
lebensweltlichen ansatz zu erreichen
das müssen wir weiter diskutieren es hat
sich viel getan in der zwischenzeit
dann hatten wir hier noch ein weiteren
text der jetzt sehr neuwahl verkennen
impulse sind wird magic transformation
of strategic
community network
dieses interesse zeitschrift sind esel
erschienen und auch hier möchte ich ein
zitat vorlesen weil das jetzt in meinen
augen sehr gut zeigt wie wir die
entwicklung künstlicher neuronaler netze
mit der geschichte der philosophie eine
verbindung setzen können er sagt in auto
fischer intelligent riesen research es
demonstrated remarketing potenzial auf
die kontrolleure networks die swans mit
state of die outperformance in new
domain sweet special und es soll
software it difficult passagier des
creation fast skeptisch ford will be on
the edge of intelligence
its troop difficult explained by design
and performance sogar ein verlassener
fünf meint impulse suggested that
komplex kosmischen is based on
information die wir von century
experience offene peeling tour verkauf
extraction
komplex play pause verkürzte auf obst
virtual works in display partei dies tue
question studenten youtube benefit aufs
display forderte die auf tecchannel
features des zements von early on
network and to implement vorläufig
assessing the talk transformation
abstraction hier finde ich sehr reizvoll
was schon bei hubert dreyfus an der ja
auf wittgensteiner heilige eingegangen
ist hier der versuch die neueren
technischen entwicklung technologischen
entwicklung auf paradigmen die
philosophie
anzuwenden zu übertragen in diesem fall
auf empirismus und rationalismus auf der
anderen seite ihr geht jetzt also um
abstraktion wie wir basierend auf
sensorischen sinneseindrücken
konzeptionen wie wir davon weiterkommen
zu begriff also wie können wir diese
abstraktion leisten das stellt die
philosophie von große probleme und
bugner sagt das kann können die scans
sehr gut erklären dann hatten wir uns in
einer nächsten sitzung mit dem thema ki
und wirtschaft ökonomie befasst und hier
uns mit dem startup jr befasst wir
hatten es genannten practice und wer
sich dafür interessiert für die
diskussion die präsentation oben rechts
macht den link rhein zu dieser sitzung
das ist das logo und hier gab es dann
die un sustainable development goals
auf die
hotel verschiedene unternehmen
betrachtet hat man kann sagen diese gold
sind gewisse muster auf die hin eben
diese muster erkennen kann trainiert
wurde und zwar auf eine sehr komplexe
weise also hier nur ein beispiel
14.03 health well before
oasis das ist ein kriterium
eine klassifikations merkmal nachdem auf
dass man hin verschiedene ätherisch
gegebene datenmengen von unternehmen hin
analysieren kann das macht eben youtube
ich bringe noch eine grafik das war
jetzt am beispiel von apple und hier
sieht man also der den negativen oder
positiven impact der stg social
programmes zum beispiel wird hier sehr
positiv gemessen bei rtl ich denke das
ist einleuchtend warum alle diese geräte
zur vernetzung der menschen wesentlich
beitragen hier sieht man die ganzen
weiteren kriterien die man hier
anlegen kann und hier gibt es bei
einigen auch negative aber bei einigen
auch positiv für
ausschläge der bewertung fand ich ganz
interessant dann hatten wir uns generell
der frage nach der ethik künstliche
intelligenz nicht mehr nur ökonomie
sondern diesmal ethik der künstlichen
intelligenz zu gewinnen anhand des
oxford brookes auf fx auf was ich sehr
empfehlen kann und hier hatten wir einen
aufsatz mit dem titel die fx auf die fx
offen diskutiert auch hier möglich
zentrales zitat bringen was mir sehr
wichtig zu sein scheint dieses auf die
presse ist der kommende burgess may not
be the fish by marriott youtube
transformations major auf ein bisschen
science engineering and culture gilt
vorerst sechs heft an das stück
entwickelt konzepte agency
responsibility intention autonomy
virtualnights der des parents and
interest ordensfrau und omas exklusiv
vom islam uns abstimmen kognitiv
mobility ein riesenbaby
affair kleid rtx akkorden mit ließ
konzept schon tools ed hardy fischer
d'elegance nur change or seines konzepts
und marcel wyss sz beginn total gäste
problem auf continued umicore existenz
mit tempo rappt ihre intelligenz ist
the world challenge the very well the
truth about fx vom lenya es korrekt
normaler prozess wie need to address die
fx offerieren in the future
also es geht darum dass dieses phänomen
der künstler intelligenz ihm auch
herkömmliche traditionelle
begrifflichkeiten transformiert und und
es geht darum dass wir das verhältnis
von künstliche intelligenz und uns
menschen die hier jetzt als koexistenz
bezeichnet hat dass wir die ethisch
angemessen reflektieren und hier stellt
sich eben die frage ob wir künstliche
intelligenz angemessen als ein werkzeug
betrachten sollten oder vielleicht noch
stärker als etwas was ein moment unserer
lebenswelt ausmacht kann vielleicht
sogar auf als lebensform das muss man
genauer diskutieren und da haben wir
dann auch noch einige interessante texte
dazu diskutiert in den folgenden sitzung
aber zunächst ging es einmal noch mal um
die ästhetik der künstlichen intelligenz
dieses bild hat eine künstliche
intelligenz erstellt ich nach oben
rechts den link zu der sitzung hinein
das ist das porträt top-mann der bel ami
und es wurde versteigert 2018 für über
400.000 us dollar wurde mit diesem
algorithmus erstellt und dieser
algorithmus sehr viel wie ich damals
bereits erklärt hatte in zwei
komponenten einem generator
diskriminiert das heißt die ki wurde
intern differenziert und auch noch in
ein verhältnis gesetzt so dass auf einer
datenbasis von 15.000 porträts das ist
die empirische basis
neuartige
kunstwerk porträts geschaffen werden
konnten die irgendwann für die ki selbst
nicht mehr unterscheidbar waren von den
original und dann war eben der moment
gekommen wo dieses bild entstehen konnte
ja und hier sieht man eben es weist
gewisse nähe zu zeitgenössischen
künstlern auf
und dann hatten wir uns noch mit einer
akustischen form von künstlicher
intelligenz und ästhetik befasst dem
beethoven ex projekt
da wurde die zehnte sinfonie von
beethoven anhand von bestimmten
fragmenten von endet es gab eben 40
skizzen dazu und auch hier wurde die ki
trainiert und zwar gewissermaßen
biografisch auf beethovens eigenen
werdegang seine entwicklung das finde
ich ganz originell und dann gab es die
frage wie eben eine melodie entwickelt
werden konnte und wie diese melodie
harmonisiert werden konnte das hat die
technikerinnen und techniker von große
auswahl gestellt ja so sieht das cover
aus dann hatten wir uns der nächsten
sitzung mit emotionaler künstlicher
intelligenz befasst hier ist ein
wichtiges buch von kathrin ein bisschen
haben künstliche intelligenz um empathie
hier lese ich auch ein zitat vor nach
oben rechts energie zu sitzen der
begriff der emotional künstliche
intelligenz englisch auch effektiv
computer wurde in den 1990 er jahren im
zuge der debatte um die emotionale
intelligenz geprägt sie lässt sich
analog zur künstlichen intelligenz als
diejenige disziplin definieren die sind
der nachbildung oder simulation von
emotionen zu tun hat also damit ob und
wie künstliche systeme emotionen
erkennen ausdrucken und vielleicht sogar
selbst aufweisen können hier haben wir
wieder das problem von simulation und
publikation
also haben sie es selbst die roboter
haben die selbst emotionen im safe von
quali
simulieren sie nur emotionen dann auch
hier ein wichtiges zitat die
notwendigkeit emotionaler karriere wuchs
aus der einsicht dass emotion eine
wichtige rolle für intelligentes
verhalten spielen so gibt es nur
wissenschaftliche evidenz dafür dass
emotionale stimmung aufgrund einer
hirnverletzung zu irrationalem verhalten
führen das kann selbst dann vorkommen
wenn die kognitive fähigkeit im engeren
sinn die sich durch einen klassischen
eco test messen lassen nicht
beeinträchtigt und als hier geht es
unser zusammenspiel von abstrakter
kognition und
emotionaler koalition das heißt sie gibt
es eine nähe eine verwandtschaft und
deswegen kann man auch hier kann
trainieren und anwenden hier kann man
natürlich sagen dass eben auch emotionen
gewissen musste darstellen die simuliert
werden können das war hier ein vorschlag
zur klassifikation von katrin also
emotionen stimmung empfindung und hier
sieht man es gibt körperliche
veränderungen die als muster genommen
werden können um eben die emotionen zu
erkennen das ist promotionen in ihren
augen gefallen die frage natürlich immer
können subjektive erlebnisqualität auch
erkannt werden ist das subjektive auch
ein prinzipielles muster für künstliche
genc fassen und sich befindet das ist
eine ganz spannende frage ich persönlich
aber eine andere auffassung der
klassifikation klar wo eben dass man
gefühle von effekten noch stärker
unterscheiden muss hier habe ich ein
paar beispiele und ich glaube dass
emotionen ausgezeichnet sind durch die
motivation ahlen aspekt den sie auch mit
effekten teilen anderen diese stärke
energie haben unterschied zu bloßen
stimmung oder gefühl dass auch im
gegensatz zur fetten promotion reflexion
dazu kommt wie zb indem der emotionen
der 8
aber darüber kann man noch weiter
diskutieren möchte ich jetzt nicht
weiter ausführen dann haben wir uns in
einer sitzung dem thema kay und
rationalismus zugewendet hier ist für
die kurzwahl die galionsfigur ein
grandioser
erfinder techniker der hier ein buch
geschrieben hat ein single ladies näher
als ergebnis um
entwicklungen die sich als exponentiell
beschreiben glas dir geht es natürlich
nicht mehr nur um eine connector von der
touring sprachen hier gibt es mehr als
um nur vermutungen die ja philosophisch
sehr sinnvoll sind hier geht es noch
mehr geht es eigentlich um spekulation
und die halte ich für problematisch weil
sie einfach zu viel wollen und eben auch
gewisse kritische einwände nicht
genügend in meinen augen reflektieren
aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es ein
faszinierendes unternehmen mal voraus zu
denken wie das ganze sich entwickeln
könnte hier sieht man eben dass das
ganze exponentiell zunehmen und so dass
hier irgendwann in einer fernen zeit ein
zustand erreicht werden könnte wo die
steigerung der intelligenz zunahme ist
so großes das vielleicht was neues
energie rdx was das ist die frage hier
ein weiteres buch the age of the machine
small computer system intelligence also
können computer wirklich geistige
maschinen seien spiritu besitzen sie
emotionen haben sie quasi als subjektive
zustimmen das möchte ich im zweifel
stellen ein weiteres buch was auf starke
kritik an diesem transnistrischen ansatz
gibt es von julian nida-rümelin und
natalie weidenfeld der das buch digitale
organismus eine ethik für das zeitalter
der künstlichen intelligenz und
lesenswertes buch hier noch mal ein
zitat ks handel nicht nach eigenem
bekunden sie haben keine gefühle kein
moralisches empfinden keine intention
und sie können diese anderen personen
auch nicht zu schreiben ohne diese
fähigkeiten aber ist eine angemessene
moralische praxis nicht möglich um eine
berechtigte oder unberechtigte bitte
unterscheiden zu können ist es
erforderlich die becken der person
richtig einzuschätzen ihre motive zu
erkennen und ihre interessenslage zu
berücksichtigen auch die besonderen
verpflichtungen gegenüber nahestehenden
lassen sich nur auf der grundlage
geteilter internationalität sharon
internationalität und geteilte emotionen
bestimmt selbst das motiv des
wohlwollens setzt ein gewisses maß an
empathie für die fähigkeit sich in die
empfindung schlagen andere
hineinzuversetzen deinen computer nicht
über qualia verfügt gehen ihnen die
entscheidenden kriterien moralischen
urteilskraft verfügt nicht über
moralischen urteilskraft sondern könnte
diese allenfalls all ihren also hier
urteilskraft spannendes thema auch hier
wieder keine duplikation
realisierung moralischen urteilskraft
nach nie darüber zur simulation
naja ob
es nicht vielleicht doch urteilskraft
hat muss man auch diskutieren am ende
jetzt dieser
zusammenfassung ich bin da eigentlich
recht optimistisch dass man das durchaus
als urteilskraft bezeichnet kann
hingegen bin ich selbstkritisch dass
computer so was wie quali haben aber
urteilskraft sehe ich jetzt nicht
unbedingt als etwas was direkt ein quali
sein müsste hier wieder eine kritik von
nida rümelin an der aktuellen künstliche
intelligenz die ich ein bisschen jetzt
ja ich bin ein bisschen optimistischer
was das anbelangt er spricht hier vom
ärger mit der digitalen
übersetzungsprogramme ich bin sehr
beeindruckt vom typ l und so weiter da
hat sich einiges getan da kann man sehr
gut mit arbeit mit lage hier noch ein
weiterer punkt wenn die grünen der
ebenfalls unberechenbarkeit theorie
gödel spricht und das überträgt aus dem
menschlichen geist und eben damit die
these vertritt dass der menschliche
geist ich nicht argumentieren lässt um
insofern auch künstliche intelligenz
niemals die menschlichen geist gleich
kommen kann
jetzt möchte ich eine zusammenfassung
geben was mein august wird die essenz
dieses ganzen seminars wird das semester
hinweg verteilt war und zwar scheint mir
das thema muster und lebenswelt ganz
wichtig zu sein künstlichen neuronalen
netzen wir haben uns jetzt nächstes jahr
auf den symbolischen ansatz konzentriert
sind auf den connect zionistischen
ansatz
also künstliche neuronale netze die
haben es wesentlich mit mustererkennung
zu tun mustererkennung hat sowohl eine
formale algorithmischen wie aus einem
material eine empirische seite das heißt
die algorithmen müssen immer ansätzen
von der datenbasis und diese datenbasis
kann ganz verschiedene art sein muster
insofern lassen sich auf ganz
verschiedene weise verstehen und
strukturieren unsere lebenswelt in ganz
verschiedenen bereichen möchte mal ein
paar beispiele geben die wirtschaft zum
beispiel wir haben sie mit wirtschafts
mustern und wirtschafts konstellationen
zu tun das beauty gesehen dass wir die
unternehmen bewerten können auch unter
anderem vielleicht auf ethische musste
damals verhaltens muss das gibt auch
andere kriterien für ethische gut hat
die wir als muster verstehen können das
heißt wir können durchaus mit chaotische
verhältnisse musste bestimmen jedoch
nicht subjektive motivation also die
qual jahr die wir in uns finden was war
der grund für meine handlung in uns
hinein schauen kann kann so meine ich
nicht man muss sie hat immer nur eine
äußerliche seite die sie erkennen kann
also zum beispiel unsere hautreaktion
bei bestimmten entscheidung aber das ist
natürlich nur die juristisch das ist
nicht was in uns wirklich vorgeht also
gründe von sein verhalten kann kann so
scheint mir nicht direkt erkennen nicht
direkt aber vielleicht vermittelt durch
andere medien wie uns raum oder unser
unsere handlungen dann die ästhetik auch
hier haben wir es mit mustern zu tun die
erkannt werden können zum beispiel
komposition muster wie haben sie das
gesehen bei beethoven wir können keine
als muse ein benutzen als
variationsmöglichkeiten und wir können
auch emotionen erkennen eben akustisch
zb aber auch visuell anhalt und zvs
gesichtsausdrucks wir können auch die
stimme auf emotionale gehalt hin
erkennen die stimme liefert muster
dann haben wir noch mit der medizin zu
tun hier gibt's krankheit musste die
entweder visuell dem auch akustisch und
sogar olfaktorisch erkannt werden können
ich kann mir schließlich haben wir auch
noch sprache sprachmuster die wir ebenso
wie will man dann der geschriebenen
stift als auch akustisch erkennen lassen
können durch können das heißt cali ist
so meine ich jedenfalls mehr als nur ein
instrument wie zum beispiel ein hammer
den ich greifen muss sondern sie wird
immer mehr teil unserer lebenswelt und
immer weniger sichtbar sein instrument
und zwar wird sie immer mehr teil der
lebenswelt im sinne einer erweiterung
unseres denkens vielleicht sogar auch
unsere fühlens unseres handelns und
andere dimension unseres künstlerischen
schaffens so verstanden hat
lebensweltliche kari nichts mit
transformers zu tun obwohl wir sie
durchaus als lebensweltlichen
bestandteil generelle kann mir nennen
könnten aber daraus folgt nicht dass
kein irgendwie selbstbewusstsein hat
oder sogar irgendwann die weltherrschaft
an sich reißt und abschließend möchte
jetzt wieder drei diskussionsforen
formulieren wo wir gleich eine
gruppendiskussion übergehen die erste
frage ist wo finden sich noch muster in
der lebenswelt die von cani erkrankt
werden kann ich habe jetzt schon ein
paar genannt die zweite gruppe befasst
sich mit der frage wie differenziert
kann die mustererkennung prinzipiell
ausfallen also das vermisste arten gibt
es wie stehen die zueinander
und drittens die frage die mir zwar auch
zu sammeln wo liegen die grenzen der
muster erkennen also ist wohin reicht
prinzipiell kann prinzipiell ja
erreichen und sie mit der künstlichen
neuronalen netze und wo sind die grenzen
das sind die fragen die wir heute
diskutieren wollen danke ich für die
aufmerksamkeit und wünsche allen
zuschauern und zuschauer eine schöne
vorlesungsfreie zeit